investigating a driver that crashed
through a wall and into a pool this
morning happened at a home near bermuda
and windmill about 3 a.m kate houston
spoke to the homeowner as they assessed
all that damage
concrete debris and car parts are
littered across this backyard the
homeowner tells me this is going to be
tens of thousands of dollars in repairs
i've lived in this house for 24 years
and
i've never seen
a car come to defense any place victor
estes says his wife was home when a
dodge durango smashed through his
backyard wall and plunged into the pool
saying it sounded like a bomb heard the
tire screeching and didn't heard the
crash
came downstairs and
he was
climbing out there's now a gaping hole
in the concrete wall and large chunks of
the fence and rock in the pool part of
the bumper is still there with an organ
license plate estas says the car floated
for hours contaminating the water with
oil and antifreeze the pool will have to
be drained and re-plastered and probably
the deck lots be running down too
because it's all
it's all tore up police suspect the
driver was impaired he was taken to the
hospital with minor injuries he had been
going fast enough to lose control and
still have enough speed left going
sideways to come through the wall
despite this happening right before the
holidays estes is thankful his wife the
driver and his dog made it out okay got
no control over stuff like this no
control
it's all good nobody was badly hurt so
that's the important thing kate houston
live local now